so bitterly about your Goblin friends is
it time I apologize is it time Sebastian
I hope we can finish what we started
with the triptych please meet me at the
southern coast
and search for the final canvas piece
no it's not time yet
it's almost time
but it's not quite time
all right so it is locked our next Quest
which is the final trial I believe all
we have to learn bombardo first oh wait
so no we have to do the one with
Sebastian is our next Story Mission
there
that's our next Story Mission
I received an owl from Sebastian it
seems despite our earlier disagreement
he would like to resume our search for
the final piece of the triptych he's
apparently found a lead on its location
and wants to meet me
along the coast to the southeast
all right let's go dude we're ready
that Relic is the key to saving Anne I
know it meet me outside of feldcraft as
soon as you can whoa
okay whoa that was weird
Sebastian I just I got your other your
other letter and I heard your voice
talking at the same time I received that
you were looking at me thank you I'm
glad you came I spotted droves of Round
Rock's loyalists coming up from the
coast
overheard one of them say they're headed
to another cabin yeah that was trippy
step ahead of us
can't know about the triptych I don't
know
I did see another memory this time it
was a keeper named Neve Fitzgerald she
was unnerved by isadora's use of ancient
Magic
they'll can't be sure how any of it
connects to Round Rock these keepers are
playing games with you you need to press
them for more information it doesn't
work like that
access each of these memories I have to
complete a trial it's not as easy as you
think they're showing me the memories in
a particular order they
either they don't trust you or you don't
care enough about and to us the
difficult questions
I do care about Anne but I'm tired no be
mean to him
that's that's not what I meant I
we're just not getting answers I need
answers
for Anne I know now should we send
letters while you're standing right next
to him I know
let's go I know I've always spotted
keep close eye out I saw some of Round
Rock's crew welcome in to the new
followers thank you guys
raiding I imagine this mountain used to
safeguard local Hamlet valuables
but it's been abandoned ever since Round
Rock took all of the coast let's go up
here
oh we didn't uh we didn't get rid of
them Marielle we just have them
disabled for this playthrough
whenever I'm doing this play through
especially when we first started out we
didn't have all the
like one of our big things was
changing what I was wearing and we
hardly had any stuff unlocked
and honestly like especially when we
have new people in the Stream
I feel like it can get really
distracting whoa it bounced off that
dude
[Applause]
okay you guys are just a little bit
rough up here
put me down how about
yeah
we might have to actually like level up
our gear here pretty soon
because everything is starting to hit a
lot harder
I mean we are playing on hard mode but
I've just I've barely been paying
attention to the
gear upgrades we've only kind of
casually been checking in on it every
now and then I know we're down to four
wiggin welds too good point hey
look at that
would you look at that
this attitude is why I don't like him I
know
I know
so many people love Sebastian I'm like
show them that clip right there
show them that clip
oh wait can I not hop on my broom right
here
Tilly and Q quagen
that is probably so wrong
thank you all for the follow
s overhead
some consider them a bad omen hmm
not everyone does
I know that
all right
oh it's one of those things that comes
in silence I'm not even worried about it
right now
oh my goodness Paula that is crazy
one day 19 hours I love it though I love
it though
thank you for the support Paula
appreciate it
now everybody's gonna
air everybody's gonna be checking the
watch time
okay wait a second do I have to oh here
we go
about to say
I didn't know it cut up like cut up the
side of the mountain like that
I know the Goblins like put me down nah
how about a little crucio for you sir
I didn't like your tone when you said
that
hey sounds good Tim
hope you find a good snack I might have
to get me a snack here shortly too
okay wait why
that is so weird it looked like it was
burning with incendio but it wasn't
going all the way through
I'm sorry we can both see thestrals
certainly not something I'd hope to be
down in common
oh that's interesting that you can
find this little
oh wait is this oh it's a Merlin puzzle
right there
yeah we haven't been doing those much
either
wonder if defindo would have worked I
maybe
there they are
let's go wait
we should have some sort of plan I'm
through planning oh dang he's just done
someone's here
yep get Imperial right away
get crucio going right away
oh dude do I have any of these ready to
go we got three Thunder Brew
all right let's actually Chinese
chomping cabbage
and then I'm gonna have a thunder Brew
ready to go too
Thunder Brew time
oh come on
did we get him that quick oh we got one
more up here
is that it
I think he's the last one anyway
I think he's the last one
all right maybe I went a little
overboard I don't know that we needed
the cabbages and the Thunder Brew there
we took care of it Ted goblins it could
have got us killed but I didn't
yeah there's it's his parents
ominous ominous tells us that
all right keep going
oh there should be more
yes look at this stocking up on the
weekend worlds
it's like the game could see hey you're
getting low
let's give you a few more Wigan welds
gonna make everyone pay anything made
from Goblin silver belongs to us whether
it's a sword or a repository whatever
that is
did you hear that Goblin
ridiculous Notions of ownership
he is so over it man
wait did I miss Blaster Blaster thank
you for the follow I don't think I saw
that one
I need to pulse there oh come on I
should have launched him
[Music]
there we go kringo launched him
that's what I was going for with the
first time
um
Rebellion
all right this is my little lumos here
yeah confringo is really good
once I got that I hardly used incendio
at all even though incendio is good when
they're close up but they have to be
really close like you almost have to use
accio to set it up
oh wait actually I wonder if this is
bombardo yep
Rebellion
eat that when you cast rebellio it
lumos just completely goes out
what in the world oh dude this is the
Basilisk area
I'm almost positive your chicken coop
inspection will occur in two weeks time
in accordance with the ministry's
investigation into rumors of the illegal
breeding of basilisks please ensure that
your premises are toad-free and be
reminded that the punishment for such
illegal breeding Endeavors is lifelong
detention and Azkaban please contact the
Department of Regulation and control
magical Beast Ministry of magic with any
questions
I'm actually going to screenshot that
too okay so I want to reference that
again in a video or something at some
point and then you can actually see
the chickens right here too
oh dude imagine if they had left some
sort of uh
some Easter egg or some other sign that
he actually did
hatch a basilisk
like imagine if you found toads up here
too
this will be a legendary here
[Music]
who needs dwarf tossing I know what the
I still wonder if they didn't intend to
have a dwarf toss minigame in there
because of what you can see in the art
book if you guys didn't know about this
there's a
I think it's called gnome toss in the
art book
JC fortnite with the follow welcome in
Keen to help him achieve his goals in
that regard
I mean just starting every fight
immediately with
perusio and imperio
I definitely feel like is the way to go
I'm way up here too
I was laid on the protego
who is
[Music]
dude I need to be doing that more it's
belly arms and then
it's badly armis and then throwing it
back at them
why are you suddenly so cautious doing
well JC doing well thank you for
stopping by I agree and frustrated
but charging ahead now could undo all
the progress we've made Lord God said oh
your Goblin friend stop it that's enough
not all goblins are like ran Rock
I am not the enemy you just told him
right we want the same thing
to find answers I thought we wanted the
same thing we do listen to me
Lord got insights into ran rock that we
don't he told me that ranrock somehow
knows about the keepers and is searching
anywhere connected to each of them
that's why they always seem to be one
step ahead
I know what I'm doing
you need to trust me or yeah back off
dude see that we can continue together
fine
I'm sorry
I'm letting my emotions get the better
of me
and I have been for a while I do trust
you
and I don't think I can help Anne
without you good
good Round Rock clearly knows more than
we thought yeah that's what I was gonna
say yeah just go charging in we have our
work cut out for us
we need to work together if we're going
to find the final piece to the triptych
yeah it was actually discovered that it
was the uh
the um the giant squid tentacle kind of
glitching through some people thought it
was a basilisk that you could see in the
Slytherin
common room
which is kind of hilarious on its own
too
that is pretty hilarious
revelio
almost here guys almost here yes more
Wigan welds too all right we're in nine
Wigan welds hard mode Let's see what we
got here we got two cabbages venomous
tentacula the adira's potion Maxima
potion
uh two Thunder Brews one invisibility
potion which I don't even know why
that's in the game it it's last four
seconds like what's the point man you
have disillusionment anyway all right so
we've we've got a decent Supply here I
think we'll be okay
I think we will be okay in there and I
think we will probably discover maybe a
few more Wigan welds in here along the
way
so far so good
Charming
and we do still have on the
Arachnophobia mode how fitting
just because I think it's funny
and kind of creepy at the same time
even the Arachnophobia mode
okay
hit the ancient magic right there
I mean there is so much going on right
now
no
yes I knew if we could get an incendio
right there we had so many surrounding
us
yeah get crucial on the big one right
there
also my reign with the follow thank you
oh come on we just missed
all right I'm gonna try to get through
this fight without using a Wigan weld I
mean because it's literally the first
fight in here
are there more oh right there
and then I think there's one more that's
still over here but let me just wait
here for a second because I hear the
music stopping yeah so there we go we
can reach in
regenerate that Health save the Wigan
weld
let it go all the way up and then we'll
jump into this next fight down here but
it looks like it's just one
wait where is that
oh this is just for a little
it's for 19. oh wait hold on though hold
on
there's a chest over here
right there it is
in that chest might have fallen oh I
think three of them
and then we've got something waiting on
us
look at that
something waiting on us right here
oh it's stuck up there no way
I think it's actually stuck
can I get up here oh there we go
no it's kind of glitched
you saw how it kind of just slid down
all right I'm just gonna do this just to
just to get rid of it
don't want it sneaking up on us anywhere
guys you know what this means because
that Sebastian
we already received that other letter
from US
I'm sure we taste better than a goblin I
think we can learn AK after this
Chrissy good night I didn't even realize
you were still here Chrissy thank you
again for the raid I appreciate it
hope you all had a wonderful stream as
well
Imperial
dude that transformed
I know I've said it once but it is so
good
no how about an Acura
accio into incendio annoying little
beasts aren't they
all right
a stack is leading here
whatever four
I don't think anyone's been here another
49.
49 gold
drink
oh my goodness
[__] my glitch now okay
I mean we can't just leave them up there
guys
that's just wrong
even for Lord retro Mort
Gage more coming up
yeah we definitely need to look to
upgrade especially before we do the last
few missions
already my stuff well really the final
boss fight is kind of the main one that
we wanna
fingers
[Music]
the Viking burial indeed
oh man
again trying to save my oh yeah we
didn't even take that much damage but
yeah ain't more ancient magic which
probably help too
no I'm trying to
get the guy right in front of me
oh my goodness that still didn't take
that one out
stupid fight
of course
the thornback matriarch so much helped
no
thank you
that it
made one more oh I think he's there we
go
all right that was pretty intense
that was pretty intense right there okay
now we need to hit I think it's three of
them again right one two yeah we've seen
Rune symbols like these before Oh
Sebastian oh my goodness dude good
finger
oh we leveled up too you know what else
I realized we probably have a lot of
Talent points to spend
can't get out of here quick enough
come on
gosh dude was I too far away
oh no good good good
very nice very nice
and would you look at this more wig and
weld
that is perfect didn't use any to this
point
and we just got three more
we should look for more why couldn't she
have kept all our journal entries in one
place
dungeon
this is a normal troll right oh mountain
troll okay
I should have imperialed the troll
s
oh I did not think he was gonna do that
as soon as we get Imperial back
we have to cast it on him
okay we got it
oh no now we got it
yeah there we go
and watch the troll go crazy on those
spiders
oh my goodness look at that dude
come on get him get him get him get him
get him
I'm just gonna stand back and let him do
the work
all right now he's now he's done
hit a troll with its own Boulder we got
that
oh there's another spider over there
we'll just Imperial him again
I think did we get rid of the final
spider
maybe it's fashion oh here it is wait
what it was there
look at him he's just standing over
there
what a great minion I know right
that's what everybody kept telling me is
like whenever you
play with the dark arts it just makes it
so op when there's a troll around
dude he still has a lot of Health though
yeah a lot of these spells just don't do
a lot of damage
oh my goodness
dude how does he still have this much
help
oh my goodness
I'm just casting Eric
what what
in the world you just teleported
that troll just operated right there
oh I was waiting for that one
okay now we've got ancient Magic
the health on this guy dude
look at this
okay we absolutely need to upgrade
I mean dude basic shot is doing 12.
and it's barely even putting a dent
glacius Defender does 230 that that
makes a little bit oh no
no I can't move
I'm
no way
oh my gosh we're gonna have to do that
all again
oh we're gonna have to do that all again
why is he even with uh
imperio
he's level 29.
I'm skipping this time
he's level 29 and what am I
think I'm like 24 27 okay
all right imperio on him right away so
that's gonna help us with the spiders
oh we don't actually have to deal with
spiders this time okay that makes it
good
oh no wait there they are there they are
they are back
yeah we could use some plants here true
true true
burning enemy oh my gosh
there we go
all right we cannot die this time
no what in the world just happened
all right get rid of all the spiders
I'm Gonna Save My ancient magic for him
honestly we need to work up to two
ancient magics
yes Sheena and army Sergeant welcome in
thank you all for the follows all right
so let's first
come on do it do it do it throw your
throw the ball there
he goes
nice hit him with imperio
how do we not have crucial already what
crucio okay now we're gonna do an
ancient Magic
my goodness look at that barely does
anything to him
all right now hold on you guys are
saying yeah let's I mean I don't have
this upgraded at all but let's get a a
plant going too
Imperial on him again
oh wait why are you what is this
what what is it walking onto right there
exactly the one thank you for the follow
can you actually do that on this one
exactly no way if you can
that is gonna be so funny
all right let's try
oh wait wait can you just Spam it like
crazy
I thought it was gonna insta
oh dude this is so weird
this is so weird
it does a thousand damage to him though
oh my goodness
yo thanks for the tip I'd heard of that
I just didn't even I didn't even think
about trying it on this one
that is too funny
all right it's getting close and do it
again
a thousand wrench every time
let's go yo shout out to exactly the one
with the pro tip right there see I'm not
a dark arts guy man I didn't use them
any on my first playthrough I had I knew
about it but I just completely forgot
about that is this the way right
I'm not sure what I did to deserve that
oh yeah if I did have that trait Dustin
speaking of trade speaking of Trades
let's check that because we've gotten so
many
or talents rather
okay but and by so many I mean two
all right we're about to learn about a
cadaver after we finish this mission
and we still got what 13 more levels to
go so we're gonna get 15 more
Talent points total
all right let's see what else we might
want to do
that could probably be useful confringo
yes I want to do that one because I use
a lot of confringo
I think I'm gonna do that
and then let me see what I haven't
unlocked from the core yet
basic attack basic cast impacts on
Airborne enemies contribute more to the
ancient magic meter
perfect patego releases a damage oh yeah
I need to do that one
Stupify deals direct damage on impact
okay that one's more important
especially the way I like to play oh
that one's important too though
have a glimpse of how much we how much
fun we morally bankrupt slytherins have
had with the game
right
oh dude yeah I've seen so many videos
and so many
shorts and stuff
I feel like
like this one first then I'll come back
and hit that one
then I'll hit that one
all right let's move on
still finding out new things I know it's
so cool all right wait is this a giant
repero situation he made a mess of
things I think it is
oh no is it not
dude look at I still want to know what's
going on over here
what is this this weird
Rebellion this weird area that I can
lock onto
or no apparent reason
repairer
I thought it was a repair okay we just
weren't in the right spot
that was a piece of
piece of more than one
you just weren't quite in the right spot
see if it screams oh my goodness you
morally bankrupt slytherins indeed
I'm not sure what I did
not sure what you did to deserve that
what are you talking about dude
what are you talking about Sebastian a
John Lund tree
is it I remember this room
I remember this room for my first
playthrough
wingardium levios
dude look at that
look at that
what is going on right there
hey more Wigan welds too
all right so that replaced I think we
did use at least two in there
levio saw
it's Leviosa not Leviosa
a lot of breath after all of those
stairs but the view
really worth it
no you tried that counts for something
bro
I'm about to go down there and get it
just for that
just for you saying that Sebastian
I'm going all the way back for it
dude why did that move why did that move
back wait more did I just miss this
earlier I think I missed it all right
I'm glad we came back here
okay it's it's in here right it's this
room isn't it
wait where is it there it is huh
take that Sebastian all for the tanned
cloak
all for the tanned cloak
all right now let's go back up there
hey yep
dude every time I do that Muriel
somebody always says you can do that
I'm like
you guys gotta watch my YouTube videos
Man
watch the videos
I've talked about all this uh in our in
our videos
but yeah you can in fact accio the loot
bags
yeah there you go Damia with the YouTube
shout out thank you
uh yeah I've talked about it
and for sure one video maybe even two
videos that I've mentioned the accio
loop bags
I know we talked about it on stream
before too
all right more money there
I know you could accio tacos
good news
John Legend sounds worrisome
there is a spot on the floor above us
is her weird
message from my computer
don't know what it was
dream is still alive okay I think we're
good
as long as we're still streaming I think
we're good
almost as good as if I'd done it myself
yeah there's a little area you can go
here this place currently belong to only
as Adora
pointed us here
another 62. IO
another loop bag
yeah I mean in the
in Goblet of Fire here he's like accio
Firebolts
because isn't that a thing in the books
he's like asking Hermione how
what's the range of the spell
I forgot where the last one is behind
here
by now
don't fall
I'm not sure what I do to deserve that
[Music]
Rebellion I feel like I'm missing
something in here I remember coming back
here on my first playthrough
to get a chest or something oh wait wait
oh yes right here
no that's not it there's
oh well
the second playthrough it's fine
I don't have to go for 100
not yet anyway
not yet
is a door must have found him yeah
this room too
I know from the memories
on them naturally magic yeah
you would not want those to be
Ikea horcrux
Jester or thank you for the follow and
also messy mama
I missed that one earlier appreciate it
thank you
thank you guys for being here
and hanging out with me tonight as we
get pretty close to the completion of
our
dark arts playthrough of Hogwarts Legacy
this is our second playthrough of the
game
on hard mode as well
that's it
I've had to keep all this secret you
just finished the main quest nice what
do you think did you enjoy it on the use
of ancient Magic
I don't understand why she seems to have
gone to Such Great Lengths to tell her
story without their knowledge I wish you
could see one of her memories so do I
perhaps completing the triptych will
shed more light rebellious all right it
pulled me out of that cutscene before or
pulled me into that cutscene before I
could do this
all right more gold
looking forward to exploring more yeah
there if you haven't done like the full
100 yet
there's a lot to see and do
all right I think we're ready to go back
to the undercroft
and then I'm trying to remember how many
missions are left
we definitely want to do AK
even though that's not a required
mission that is a side side mission
go on place it
final piece
another pensive this is what we've been
chasing
I wonder
let's find out
oh he's going in
I cannot bring my brother back father
yes you caught you caught the reference
Cincinnati indeed
please have a seat
so this is after
Isadora she took it against
will right
we're ready
it has to show you
it's just so weird that that these are
my colleagues from Hogwarts
father hasn't spoken since my brother
died
on my travels you think this is before
take away it feels like it should be
before
but why would they have shown this after
that other one
here's a Dora yeah I feel like her
conversation with Neve seems like it
would be after this
but this is yeah
this is her memory
right there
I think you're right Damien I think
she's altered this memory
like in uh
you learn about in Half Blood Prince
all right
what up if you could tell me more about
what it is you're storing
but the game never confirms that does it
that it was altered or changed
because I kind of feel like it is Magic
I kind of feel like this memory
devised to remove pain but
if used correctly its power can be used
to do even more good
would you want to store such magical way
I only need to keep it safe until I can
convince myself oh it's like a C2 will
maybe maybe like this
appreciate it
perhaps not it never actually does yeah
someone will be as soon as I saw that I
thought the exact same thing I was like
oh that's been altered
that's an altered memory
I knew it
I knew there was a way to help Anne
something isn't right Sebastian
I thought our character was gonna say
she did no not the memories the portrait
I thought we were going to say the
memory I think the reason is Adora
hasn't appeared is because she can't
I don't follow
we have seen that view before the
abandoned home at felgrove the destroyed
painting it was her so someone destroyed
a bit of an enchanted canvas but we
found the memory
yes yes you're right we saw what she
wanted us to see we saw what she could
do what you can do
but I don't know how to do what is Adora
did well then you shall learn
the keepers can teach you
I'm not sure that they would
the keepers believe that removing
someone's ability to feel this one this
is my evil place here pretty complicated
unpredictable form of magic one that
should be wielded with great care if at
all at all you've overcome all of their
challenges you've more than proven
yourself you can wield it you have the
ability
please
talk to the keepers
if not for me hey have a good one
Marielle thanks for being here
good chatting with you
why did the keepers want to keep his
Adora quiet
why destroy her portrait yes
why indeed
all right so that right there
what's the next mission
I think we gotta wait a second for it to
trigger
Garrett with the follow appreciate that
welcome in
by the way if anybody is uh here I
haven't mentioned it in a while I try to
remind people every now and then if
you're here for the drops uh exclamation
point drops in the chat we'll get you
the info you need
there it is
we do have drops enabled I'm tired
I will reach out when I return
I have something to give you
Lord God getting himself into more
danger than he realized so we still have
I'd better find him
we still have a couple more missions
left a couple more main missions
because there's this one
and then I know for sure the Rookwood
one
and then
does it go into end game
all right but we have to do this one
all right so I'm gonna do I'm gonna do
this right here to progress that
and then we also need to at some point
make sure we go and
upgrade some gear but what I'm afraid of
is that I'm gonna need way more magical
creatures than I have
but I could just go by I could just go
buy a lot of the part the parts the uh
animal fur and stuff that we need
it's like a place right out of a
storybook intersect and Legolas with the
follows as well thank you all
right he's this way
Sebastian a lost Relic from a catacomb
which requires a dark sacrifice
I know how it sounds
it's worth the risk that works
he helped find a scriptorium where we
discovered slytherin's Spellbook
very well would have made more than one
portrait yeah I'll meet you
we don't have much time Solomon wants to
leave veldcroft
what
leave never mind can we go straight into
it from here's Thailand please remember
I shall do my best highest time I'll be
in touch I think we have to wait a
little bit I don't think it lets us go
straight can't take hand from feldcroft
wherever they go when would I see her
Sebastian I can't believe my uncle wants
to leave feldcroft Anne's going to stall
him she must we need time time
for what I've learned more about the
Relic
a cross-reference Slytherin Spellbook
with everything in the library on relics
and dark sacrifices that's when I
realized something I believe the Relic
will only work inside the category here
we go
we can do this you just need to get on
to the catacomba yeah you have to wait a
little bit for him to reach out right
hurdle maybe convincing ominous and
we'll only give this a chance if he's on
board and we have to keep all of this
from your uncle
if he goes to the Headmaster we could be
expelled let me handle ominous this time
as for my uncle he's not an aura anymore
what he doesn't know well that's true
he's leaving feltcraft wouldn't be
it wouldn't be a bad decision honestly
it's been rated twice now right I shall
let you know when the four of us should
meet at the catacomb look for my owl
look for your owl okay
all right so we progressed that
okay here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna try to upgrade a bunch of gear
and Glad Rags is actually a great way to
do it
but first i'm gonna go to the rumor of
requirement and we're going to
basically make sure that we
uh what's it called the
not the loom but the one that you should
be proud of all the potions you've
brewed
not the loom
this one identify the gear
all right so
let's see what upgrades we got just from
that right there
okay
none on those two all right the face
wear
it's locked
level 28 and it's not even an upgrade
that's so weird to me
but that's how it works okay no upgrade
there either
oh come on dude
yes okay
I actually have an upgrade there
all right let's switch back to our
Relic House uniform
okay good upgrade there all right I was
about to be super disappointed man
look like we only get one upgrade out of
that
I still feel like there's a better
outfit to wear underneath for this house
Relic but I've yet to find it
I have yet to find it at this point
all right okay the glow so yeah I need
to make sure those change the actually
I'm not even gonna bother changing the
appearance on stuff because now I want
to go to
I want to go to our buddy in hogsmead
lad Rags which is
right there
travel here and then we'll go in there
it's a great place if you guys didn't
know this
he almost always has
upgrades
almost always okay poppy sorry do not
wanna
dress that at this point
all right
see look at it look at that
83.85 on the gloves
okay so 85 gloves
okay now first let's sell
if I haven't said it before it's a
pleasure doing business with you
favorite characters from this game oh
that's I like that that's a good
question
I feel like ominous for sure
is one of the best overall characters
oh wait that's an okay only because I've
upgraded it all right sell that okay we
got ten thousand
all right so that would take us up
okay so we got a cloak there that's 82 a
cloak there 83.
why did they not put all the cloaks
together
84 on that one okay so that one's the
best so far 50 59.
all right so we could definitely get
this right here
[Music]
that's gonna be an upgrade
and then this is a nice upgrade
[Music]
welcome into the new follows thank you
all I prefer to be anonymous and Loco
thank you for the follows
and thank you Damia for being here to
welcome everybody in appreciate it
all right so we already got an upgrade
there
wait the scarf okay we got an upgrade
all right I think that's all we can do
at this moment you have a sharp eye for
fashion let's put both of those on and
we'll see
okay yes that's a that's a decent
upgrade right there
again I hate that we have to go in and
change the appearance each time
and the gloves yes let's do the gloves
oh okay that was a nice upgrade right
there
see I'm hesitant to put any of the
traits and all that on there though
because
I feel like I should just wait until I'm
about to do the final mission
and what we could do is we could
actually definitely go ahead and sell
the other one
you like poppy a lot as well Damia
how about you White Mamba how about you
I suspect favorite characters from
Hogwarts whenever you're about
foreign
[Music]
go back to the room of requirement
there's really no point
I will go ahead and proceed and do this
next Quest though load gox loyalty
all right let's take a look at the map
and we'll just fast travel because I'm
pretty sure this one is yeah I was gonna
say pretty far to the South
way down here Coastal mine
ominous is your favorite Poppy and Ronin
are near the top yeah trying to trying
to decide between the professors that
now that is tough
because I feel like they did such a good
job with all the professors
introducing us just to a new era of
Wizarding World professors
Ronan Ronin would be close to the top
for me sign of load [__] out here
must be inside already the coastal mine
all right here we go guys
laughs
why does it keep popping up about
equipping better gear that's literally
what we just got done doing look at the
size of this mine always makes me think
I have something that this I don't know
about
it
oh dude the one in Period
still there
just waiting
ominous is top tier Ronan and heckett
are Fab teachers
yeah I mean they all just have
I just feel like they're all so unique
and they have so many interesting
stories they could tell
about the professors if they wanted to
go down that path
all right so
I think we have to go this way right now
oh yeah heckett's story would be
fascinating to see the full uh
full details there
pleased with our problem
that has to be the end up ahead
I mean we could go stealth through some
of this but
nah not with the dark arts
not with the dark arts
yeah they could tell a lot of good
stories with each of the professors
expanded quest lines yeah I agree
I wonder where these pipes go
Rebellion
all right
more loot
I know Elwyn right it's so good
there he is enjoy suffering do y'all
that was an accidental race of elio by
the way you guys didn't know yeah
all right
all right we can use the barrel right
there oh that was good timing
nice all right
let's
Climb come on you got this
I'm pretty sure if I remember right
I'm pretty sure it's something uh boring
over here
whatever you have at the end of this
oh I can't even open it right now
it's level three never mind
I don't know what it is then I can't get
it right now
an intruder that's right
oh yeah there's a troll downstairs
inside you
and you know what we're gonna do with
him
let's get the spell ready man
imperio and watch him just go crazy
where's he at wait we could do it on
this guy
nah definitely on the troll
oh my gosh look at him dude
wait why did excuse me troll
let me get out of your way he's like I'm
just trying to do my job retro morph get
out of the way
blow up a loyalness a loyalist Sentinel
with bombardo while they charge their
magic
okay
yikes
all right I'm trying to read so much I'm
trying to read uh
all right I was gonna say I bet his
I bet it was I bet it's worn off by now
I knew it
Shadow guided oh my goodness you've been
here all this time Shadow guided
break a shield charm with an ancient
magic throw
I don't even know why I'm looking at
those it doesn't matter it literally
does not matter on this bike no
all right dude he is not
come on troll
you gotta do better than this
when we cast imperio
dude they took me out again quick
all right
there you go get him troll get him
like see if you get caught in the line
of fire though
he's just like whatever
I'm still coming your way
oh my goodness look at that they just
they attack in such quick succession all
right Thunder Brew I can see this one
being good right here
all right I think it's probably worn off
so we're gonna have to do
there we go get another imperio on him
use a wigging weld
throw that into the wall for no reason
oh man
okay wait is that it I think that's
everything except the troll
it is
all right
imperio now let's do this again man oh
he's level 31.
the one I can't believe they haven't
patched this
how is this allowed
yeah he is a tank for sure that's why I
don't feel bad about doing this
level 31 with so much health okay wait
is that it is that it I gotta back off
now
hit you with a little ancient Magic
okay ancient magic does do more than
it does do a little bit more than when
we do this and then petrificus
come on come on come on it's like you
have to wait for his body to
one more should do it
let's go
arrested
look at that
how I got him just leaning straight up
like that
all right
let's go Moving On Moving On Moving On
I know there was a chest back there but
at this point it's probably just some
gear that I'm not gonna end up using
oh okay you know what fine my curiosity
is getting the better of me
I gotta go up and see I gotta at least
take a peek at what this is
the question is where is it how do we
get it
oh wait I remember this hold on there's
actually a whole area
that you get to by going this way
we actually might need some of these
coins that's true
collection chest or two here that's what
I was thinking
I think one of them's this way
not that I would ever need to go back
and get 100 again guys not that I would
ever need to do that no no no no no
no no no no no no no we would we would
never need to do that
wait what is this right here
what is the symbol
hey welcome into the new followers
okay I'm forgetting something
maybe I have to do it from Below
it's got to be a switch or something
Rebellion think of the content though to
100 playthroughs
man
you know that might be a fun a fun
stream when I'm just
that's how I did the Merlin trials the
first time as I was streaming and it
just went by so fast when I was chatting
with you guys because so many people I
see complaining about the Merlin puzzles
and they're like oh there's way too many
but they went by fast to me because I
did it on stream and we knocked it out
in about three hours
but the three hours went I know three
hours it's like that's a long time to
just do Merlin trials but it went by
pretty quick
okay hold on what am I doing okay
there is a way to get up there you guys
hold on isn't there another elevator
oh man
levioso on that little uh platform up
there that little spot I thought it was
a switch Sunday
or no not a switch like uh one of those
things that I need to
light the fire for it
I'm not seeing one over here
okay that's the way we're supposed to go
I see there's a chest over there so
we'll get all that stuff on the way out
but then there should definitely be a
way for us to get up to that level and
we can see
there's a lift behind there oh no it's
doing the thing where it uh
because of the chat delay I have no idea
I have no idea where behind there is in
reference to
oh wait right here right here right here
I think
why do I keep feeling like there's
feeling like they're supposed to be a
lift here
I might I must be thinking about a
different area that's very similar to
this one
all right I'm gonna go back up here
okay nothing you can do there
zodiac what's up zodiac
I didn't realize that was you earlier I
know you were in here
you were in here earlier right
earlier tonight
gosh Damia I'm an idiot
too late at night
it's past midnight
you've been here the whole time oh my
gosh
oh it was just a simple levioso would
you look at that
now we can open this up oh so beautiful
we can open this
I would have probably gotten there but
it would have I
my brain isn't firing 100 this hour of
the night so
it probably would have taken me a while
all right now let's see if I can figure
out where dami was talking about there's
a lift behind there okay we still never
found did we ever find this video okay
we did it was the one that was above
there's one of those down here though
too
but we like these
okay did that open up anything
did that open up anything else
right in front of me
legendary unidentified head item
all right back up we go
and then over there I know there's
something over there we don't have yet
but I don't have the level three
okay so we got everything that was in
that area perfect
I don't have the level three lock
picking yet
Gigi welcome in
what is up indeed how are you enjoying
the game so far
how far in
are you trying to savor it or are you
just just blasting through it
because I know how excited you were to
finally get to play
level 22 oh man you've been playing a
lot then
you have definitely been playing a lot
okay is that the only two we have to
fight here no way right
I guess it was suspect
I guess it was just those two you've won
last follow around Rock
maybe a little bit too much hey you've
you've waited long enough enjoy it
however however you enjoy it best
whether that's playing it like crazy or
spacing it out well now here come the
other enemies I knew that seemed way too
small
oh
my God
no
um
[Music]
go ahead
I knew you wanted to attack me
no no no
I'm gonna try not to use a wig and will
to finish this off
I may regret this
why can't I hit you
are you sure I'm trying to save the
Wigan welds no
can we do it
yes let's go
Danny C with the follow thank you thank
you welcome in
more diverse storylines than anything
yeah there's I mean there's a lot of
things I wish
were different but at the same time I
still love the game so much
but yeah I definitely wish there was
more to do at the end
I wish they had DLC ready to go already
which I I know it's like an impossible
task to have something like that ready
that quickly but to go any further all
right I'm gonna go up here although I
think we actually leave
and we actually leave right here yeah I
think that's where we leave
right no game's perfect
very very true no game is perfect
Rebellion
revelio
oh no this is
mine never mind The Wizarding World well
yeah this is a big moment right here
I can end this right now as my road
all right troll
Imperial right away on him
oh dude this is gonna be a tough fight I
can already tell you
all right get the venomous tentacular
out
no throw that please
not at the Troll he's actually on my
side right now
all right fine we're just completely
wait is the troll the last one can we
already get rid of them no way right
oh yeah there's one up there
all the trolls trying to get him
trolls can't reach him though
troll can't reach him
saddest moment in the whole game for you
coming up oh I think I know what you're
talking about
oh we just caught him
no can I not use petrificus
it's not letting me use petrificus I
think it's because there's other enemies
in the area
all right there we go
all right we got him
now petrificus
why is it not working
oh
it's wearing off
hold on Luna hold on
we gotta beat this troll
as soon as we beat this troll I'll let
you know
come on
might be able to get him right here
come on oh and then we got an ancient
magic ready yeah
let's finish him off with the ancient
Magic
that was indeed a close one
all right
I thought this is what we're supposed to
do right here
here we go
[Music]
looking outside
Lord gok
come to make amends little brother
I came to stop this little brother
reveal
it cannot be
all this time
you knew
you knew where it was
so wrong
never understand you Lord Goku so are
you ready to go to bed that witch did
not continue unequal see like all wizard
kind really good
you're wrong
astonishing that our ancestors ever
trusted each other
all the time looking everywhere for the
final repository searching in vain for
Bradford's last journal
wasted my time chasing a child
she is so sweet agreed
we never thought she would even wow oh
she was so wild
the idea of her being a lap dog was
hilarious
oh ran Rock don't do it man
then he tries to
he tries to get ran Rock in the back
now we're getting out of there
part made me feel so horrible for
mistrusting load gawk yeah
dead by his brother's hand
the one that he tried so hard to reason
with him oh man
that is tough I think that's it I don't
think there's any more that we do in
here
revelio
I don't think
I'm trying to remember how many more
quests we have before the end of the
game
because I feel like we're getting pretty
close
pretty close to the end
but before we do that I am definitely
gonna make sure I can
upgrade my gear as much as I can
because for that final fight with Rand
Rock oh buddy we're gonna need it
uh necessi
thank you for the follow apologies for
butchering the name
but welcome in glad you're here hope
you're having a good night wait I don't
need to go back this way do I
oh yeah this threw me off the first time
I was so confused because
you're back in the exact same area
but aren't you supposed to
oh my gosh wait it's confusing me again
Tracking not available here here
and also B Mill with the follow
ing
no this is not the right way it's not
the right way
you're not supposed to have to do all
this are you here
I should remember this but
what I remember is getting very confused
in this area
all right I think we have to take this
but I'm gonna take it back
just to make 100 sure
oh you know the ending and everything oh
man
the fairy girl with the follow welcome
in
okay now it's at 94.
so it barely changed
oh wait I do see that we missed uh
I do see that we missed this
so hey it's good that we came back
anyway
just started playing now you found the
drops let's go yeah the drops are pretty
cool especially this time the drops are
really nice
2 42 P.M Monday oh my God
PM it's already that late in the
afternoon in Australia
first time watching her twitch due to
the drops you've watched the YouTube
videos a b Mill thank you appreciate
your support on the YouTube
and yeah I guess I I'm rarely streaming
at a decent hour for you
you found me due to Miranda lorian oh
that's awesome
Miranda is great
she and I uh we we really hit it off had
a great time on the uh
a trip to La we actually both got to
play the game early and we were in the
same same session
and then I don't know how it was weird
like the timing the way the timing
worked out was like everybody else that
was there on that trip that was
part of the people that I knew going in
they all had already went to
Universal
the day before
so WB they hooked us up with with
tickets to Universal to uh The Wizarding
World there
which was awesome but the rest of our
group had already went and so I was like
man I was thinking I was gonna have to
go by myself
but then uh Miranda turns out she was
going to
and so we were very glad to have
somebody to go with and talk to
but yeah I made oh dude this was right
dude that is so confusing though right
that is so confusing because you
actually have to run away from the
marker
you have to run away from the marker
and go back the way you came and if you
try to do the little tracking it doesn't
work okay I just want to take a peek
here
see if there's anything in here I need
to get okay no we're going we're going
we're going
but yeah she and I we
we just talked about YouTube like that
whole similar to fake to meet me that
whole day he and the keepers need to
know Round Rock has that journal and
knows where the final repository is
so yeah I had fun being in her Vlog and
I actually filmed some stuff that she
was in on my end but I never uh
I never got around to posting it I was I
was too busy too busy with other videos
okay I don't think we even have to fight
this troll
what is the next step here did he say
talk to Fig
we can't do that yet because it's not
maybe we have to just escape from this
area
let's get out of here the only part of
that trip that I was disappointed by the
only only part is Super Mario World was
not open yet
it was not open yet they were like it
was everything was built and it was
ready to go and they had actually been
doing a couple of uh
oh what do you call it when they kind of
like test things out so they open it up
and let some people in early
and so the day before they had opened it
up and some people from our group got to
go
but then the day we were there they
weren't doing it I was like no
no because I live on the east east coast
so like
going out that far to La that's my first
time ever in LA
okay wait is this in the map chamber I
think we're in the map chamber yeah okay
so we can just
so it'll probably be
a while before I remember back out that
way again
all right secret rooms
map chamber
soft opening yes there you go zodiac yes
never been to the one in La well the one
in Orlando is definitely bigger if you
especially if you've been there since
they added the
um Diagon Alley portion I hope Professor
Fink got my elf but yeah they're both
great I'm the keepers that randrock
knows why the last repository is you can
still get Merlin's cloak uh not from
this stream though you have to watch the
official Avalanche stream
and I don't know if they've said yet
when they're coming back
great news indeed
we had hoped for more time to discuss
the best path forward let us hear what
the student has to say yeah
hear what I have to say people professor
hear what Lord retro Mort has to say
last of bragpur's journals he killed log
to get it he knows where the last
repository is godric's Heart Lord God
were brothers
odd God was bringing the journal to me
ran rock is a monster we need to know
where the final repository is
journals and knows where the final
repository is were you obliviated
why would he have more characters
he didn't know what we were containing
it took nine hours to get on oh my
goodness
the PS exclusive Quest
yeah it's in hogsmead you have to talk
to a little house elf outside of a shop
but you do have to progress the game to
a certain point I'm not sure how far
into the game you are but
you have to be a certain ways into it I
can't remember how much exactly
uh why would he have documented all of
this he didn't know what we were
containing
is it over told bradboard about the
magic when she asked him to build a
container for her
not Memories is the daughter left
memories for someone to find
you know what she did her memory showed
what she did for her Father which I also
saw in Professor rookwood's pensive and
a conversation with bragbor in which she
expressed frustration about the limits
being placed online
basically on the memories they have seen
I believe our young friend is well aware
of the Grave circumstances in which we
find ourselves
we are well aware the next trial will
involve an exceptional level of magical
skill this one was so nuanced ability to
interact with beasts
because it really felt like the trials
were just building building I should
advise you and then you must engage with
any Beast that is part of the trial on
your own now you just have a supercar
an exceptional level of
nuanced ability to interact with beasts
hmm and I think there's something else
whatever that may be very well I totally
free zodiac has been keeping an eye on
me deathly hallows should have been the
last one there so she has no reason to
raise concerns with Professor black I
shall see you near the coast
perhaps then you can tell me a little
more about the memories of Isadora that
you witnessed
that's awesome to hear
the fairy girl awesome to hear
because I know you all waited so long
and
we're so ready to play
and I mean I honestly I was kind of
worried about how it was going to
perform but everything I've heard so far
has been
that it's holding up very well which is
a really nice
to see that I mean that the delay
clearly it was
it was put to good use you know
which is all really when those
situations happen
that's all you can ask for is that
it ends up being a worthwhile delay and
I think it was
okay crack crack Croft Shore Let's
Travel all the way down here
let us travel
see why does that keep popping up about
the better gear
there's a thing I don't know that at
this point
it always makes me think I have better
gear that I need to equip
but then I check and now I don't
watch I will this time watch
okay well those we can't do anything
with
nope not an upgrade
those are locked and not upgrades
no upgrade see like
why is it popping up
thank you for the new follow as well
welcome in
yo here I have good news we do not have
any of Rand Rock's loyalists to contend
with of course the bad news is that it's
likely because they no longer need to
track the keepers for information right
happy tears uh when it finally came out
yeah
Ryan J with the follow thank you my
friend welcome in
revelio
all right I forgot what we're supposed
to do here I think this
is that the lord of the show I believe I
know what
do you recognize the head sculpted there
of course I do and the prince carved
into the ground lead me to believe that
a grab horn will somehow open the way
forward he finished it way too fast oh
man I feel like a lot of people did that
interact with beasts it would seem so
I do know that the last of a long
dynasty of grap horns lives near but I
mean they call him you'll remember the
ride sure I suspect you'll need to bring
him here what happens next I can't say
Mrs french fries 2021 thank you for the
following I'm done I'll do it excellent
I know this area well enough when you
see the remains of a large sea creature
you're in the right place
now Professor Rackham made it clear that
you must engage with any Beast that is
part of this trial
so I shall wish you good luck and wait
for your return in the map chamber there
are actual portraits
j95 welcome in
anything else before I could actually do
this Quest
like had to get some item or some spell
or something maybe I already have it in
this playthrough I don't know
oh my goodness and we got Mr French
fries too I love it
I love it Mr and Mrs french fries both
hanging out in the Stream tonight
actually had some french fries for
dinner tonight
as a side a side item
all right wait can we actually let's see
can we fast travel oh my goodness it's
way down here but yes we do have a fast
travel Point nearby
we do indeed have a fast travel point
yeah and it's it's shown in the sales
too white Mamba it has definitely shown
in sales I mean it's made over a billion
dollars at this point
and that was before launching on PS4 and
Xbox One
this must be the place
do you guys hear that
I don't think I've ever heard that
dialogue over a hundred hours I played
this game
that was I don't even know what she said
I don't even know what she said right
there
all right you can't inner wall mounted
fine
can we use the unforgivables on this guy
show yourself it's gonna be pretty funny
if we can
I mean I have to try it right
is it just instantly in the mission
back to Imperial
oh my goodness
oh you can't use it on him
I tried guys I tried
okay that does pretty good damage what
about Imperial no
all right lots of confringo and bombard
I feel like
an ancient Magic
glacias does nothing to you how is that
possible
I know you're you're pretty strong but
I just need to keep my distance
yeah literally as I say that
Levy also does nothing
man he's so quick too
oh I'm dead
oh how did I survive that
um
yeah it's just such a weird the way he
attacks right there
come on we need to dodge him
yeah
oh he's down he's down he's down
let's go
yeah damage spells only
and that ancient magic throw
wait did I mess something up did I skip
the skip a cutscene
incendio's good but man you gotta be so
close
use potion Buffs on this that's a good
call yeah
let's see what what kind of thing oh we
do have the Maxima potion
let's do it
ow
oh come on dude
it's funny
oh that incendio was worth it
you gotta get away though
oh my goodness like there goes my 20
seconds
of having the spell damage increase
what
I'm just I don't care I will spam Wigan
Wells I am not gonna do this again
oh the tail too
I see right there
almost got him
come on get ready bombarda
oh come on he's so down
sheesh
your mom was such a huge Harry Potter
fan oh wait Neil or attack
I'm playing as evil I'm attacking him
does it do both actually work you are
going to help me
do the wave
get the plants out too
just don't have many plants
the grab horn has a powerful charge
attack that deals a large amount of
damage to enemies in certain barricades
hold L2 to initiate keep an eye on the
graph horn stamina meter as charging
will drain it
oh do you want it to fear respect you
yeah and this playthrough I want it to
fear me
fear me grabhorn
yeah
um the fairy girl I'm not really sure
what happened but yeah what what White
Mamba said very sorry to hear that she
didn't have a chance to play the game
and you know what that mission is for
you know what that mission is for
we gotta get out of here I don't even
know if I'm going the right way
dude Luna Comics uh
you had a dream last night where you
were flying a broom I love it welcome in
Luna
are you uh
okay are you Luna
what hour what hour is it for you at
this moment
wait how do I I was about to say I know
you can jog
a little bit faster
my only issue is with this is it it just
happened so late it'll take more than
this to stop a little bit ashore
it's so late in the game that you get
this
and remember the uh Brazilian Comic-Con
when they showed this
oh no they actually showed this moment
a very small snippet of it but
we're crossing like it or not Texas oh
wow
so it's what about about midnight for
you then I'm guessing you're Central
Time
[Music]
I just had to stop at that and see
sponso no way
hold on which way are we supposed to go
here
[Music]
no need to race now my friend
oh maybe we're supposed to go this way
[__] Cynthia
I don't see anywhere
I don't see any way to get through there
unless we can run run through that wall
wait maybe we do have to run through
that wall
hold on
oh right here right here right here
right here
and run through here there we go
[Music]
cut it over this way
oh and then we go up we go into that
this is the place we were trying to get
to
I need to race though my friend
stayed up all night to finish your
projects for your final day of class
tomorrow wow
yeah very sorry for your loss to fairy
girl that's tough
that is very tough
playing has made me think of how much
she would have gone crazy for the chance
to be a Hogwarts students last game she
played was the original Spyro of the
Dragon oh my goodness it's it has been
really interesting to see a lot of
people who don't play games normally or
haven't played games in a while
have still found something to uh
something about this world that that
Drew them in
like Damia
one of our moderators here never
never played games before this we just
walk in here with him I don't think we
do right
go in like this
and there is his portrait
put hubs Professor was right to have had
faith in you
I still have my reservations
Isadora as you will see was not who she
seemed
I can only hope that you are my memories
should answer any questions you may have
about the power you will need to protect
thank you Professor bakal I shall see
you back in the map chamber
I shall see you back in the map chamber
oh dude if this is the memory I think it
is
if this is the memory I think it is it's
a pretty big moment right here
yeah yeah what Damien said there big
spoiler alerts
if any of you don't want to know some of
the things
I won't say anything about it but if you
want to like click off and mute for a
second
hello
stop looking like I
this part freaked me out dude
I was just waiting for him to like grab
him or something
that look
Sean I'm glad you're here because the
daughter was not at your home I know
father
what is it
as though he was stripped not only of
his pain but of all emotion everything
is much worse than I feared
and he was right
Isadora hasn't stopped I've just learned
that she has been wielding that magic on
students
we must gather the others
hmm here we go
[Music]
all right
oh that's right dude she starts doing it
on the students
that smile man oh my gosh
everyone feels pain
and why
because of your arrogance
her Obsession and secrets
they won't suffer any longer
my father
not my students
I want
Isadora
set down your wand
yes sir
taught me to hone my power not throw it
away
I did not teach you this
expelliables
foreign
that's still surprises me
like you you're telling me that the four
of you can't
overcome her
I would have loved to have seen
what happened after that
if Percival was just like cool with with
him doing that
because the game never I mean they
really don't address it much
I mean there's a little bit more about
it but
all right let's see see what they have
to say for themselves the caverns below
Hogwarts where you fought Isadora is
that the location of the final
repository it is
you see we could not destroy the strands
of emotion Isadora had stolen from so
many
so we did all that we could to keep them
safe we also realized that until they
could be destroyed the magic used to
create them was a danger to wizard kind
hence we became keepers
keepers of an unfathomable secret we
knew that someday one with the ability
to see traces of ancient magic might be
seduced by its power we built the trials
to lead that person to us
to allow them to prove themselves worthy
of the knowledge we've kept hidden and
the responsibility that accompanies it
have I not proven myself professor
I need to get to that repository before
ranrock does you have and you will
but the repository is protected by
powerful ancient magic to enter you must
craft a special message from the four
artifacts you found above are pencils
crafting the repository is safe from
Round Rock for now if he is as you
suspect capable of using the power of
the other repository I fear he will be
able to breach our defenses then I must
go now and craft this wand
perhaps Mr Ollivander will help me
another Ollivander I'm not surprised as
I am sure he will tell you this wand may
be used for only one purpose return with
the wand only one purpose
I shall send an owl ahead to Ollivander
whilst you visit him I'll reach out to
Professor Weasley Professor Weasley yes
I may have made an error in judgment by
not informing her of branrock's
intentions earlier
I only hope it's not too late
Fran Rock really is going to try to
drill below Hogwarts we'll need all the
help we can get all right professor
I'll see you soon
I will see you soon professor
see you soon professor
all right so
all right I'm trying to trying to line
all this up in my mind of how
in the shadow of the Relic oh my gosh
okay the suggested level for that
is 28 we are almost there
we are almost to level 28.
all right so you know what actually I
think that's going to be a great place
to stop right there because there's more
than I thought left
and
I want to keep playing this game more
this week
as the to continue helping everybody
with the drops so
I probably shouldn't beat it all tonight
probably shouldn't go ahead and finish
it out